[Applause]
thank you all
very much thank you barbara and to
everyone for
first inviting me and second for
attending
so i'm gonna try to do something
very difficult this evening i'm going to
try to
put the idea of the rights
the right to free speech in the broadest
possible historical context
i want to start with a comment though
you know we we have a an idea built into
our
human rights legislation that all the
rights are equal in some sense and
that can't be true because rights
conflict with one another
and when things conflict they have to be
hierarchically organized and
what that means is that there's there's
an implication that
there is a hierarchy of rights as well
as a hierarchy of responsibilities and
that it's also
incumbent on us to determine the nature
of that hierarchy and to determine what
constitutes the sovereign
let's say the sovereign right and i
would say you might think of that as a
modern conundrum
um that would only be of interest to
countries that have formalized bills of
rights for example but
it's not a new problem it's an
extraordinarily old problem
because there's no difference between
determining the hierarchy of your rights
and determining how to live together
successfully
it is exactly the same problem one is
only articulated in a legal form
and the problem of how we should live
together um
in the most productive possible manner
everything
considered is as old as mankind itself
in fact
i would say far older than that because
the same problem
the devil's social animals way down the
phylogenetic chain and so this is an
unbelievably archaic problem now
years ago when i started thinking
i suppose in earnest um
i was trying to address what i later
recognized as a postmodern problem and
the problem was this was in in the
late 70s and early 80s when the cold war
was madly raging
um because it peaked in 1962 and it
peaked again in about 1984
thereabouts and of course at that time
people were very terrified about the
potential outcome of the cold war and
for
very good reason and i was curious about
i was very curious about this like
insanely curious about it was obsessing
me
i couldn't understand two things i
couldn't understand why the world had
divided itself into two opposing
narratives
why that had happened at all and and
also why these narratives were
of such importance to people apparently
that we were willing to arm ourselves
far beyond the teeth and risk
massive mutual annihilation to battle
out the
to battle out the conflict between these
two ways of looking at the world
and i was curious i mean first the first
question was were these merely two ways
of looking at the world
now because you might think well there's
there's no shortage of ways to live in
the world and that's a moral
morally relativistic stance and there's
something to that obviously because
people differ
people differ in occupations and they
different outlook and and so forth a
different different political belief so
there's obviously many ways that we can
thrive in the world
and so some degree of flexibility with
regards to what constitutes your
fundamental axioms
obviously is is necessary
um but there's a deeper question and and
this is a very deep question i actually
think it's a it's the question at the
bottom of the post-modern conundrum
which is whether or not there are any
um reliable meta-narratives let's say
overarching narratives that can unite
people in some fundamental way
and so i was curious were were these
just two arbitrary
ways of looking at the world both
potentially equally valid
and were we battling that out because we
didn't know and there was no other way
to battle it out or
was there something deeper at stake was
it possible that one or the other system
was
correct in some deep manner and i
believe i
do truly believe that i entered that
that universe of questions let's say
with
as open as a mind is possible because i
actually wanted to find out the answer
you know because
well it seemed to me the fundamental
question that obviously we fought a
whole cold war about it was the
fundamental question
it was this it was the question
everyone's mind should have been
concentrated on
and so i started to study deeply
this this particular question the first
question was well what were beliefs made
out of like what exactly is it
what are what are we talking about when
we talk about a belief what does it mean
that you have beliefs
how are beliefs structured you know so
that was a psychological question rather
than a political or economic question
and that took me a long time to figure
out because i didn't know if the
fundamental question was going to be
sociological or
political or or economic or
psychological and it turned out to be
psychological or perhaps it turned out
to be spiritual that's another way of
thinking about it
and
if if you could grasp belief
what would constitute a credible belief
what would it mean for a belief to be
credible
and i i can give you a little hint about
that i learned this from jean piaget the
developmental psychologists
brilliant brilliant theorist
a genuine genius he was interested in
how children organized games
and he thought of games the organize the
organization of games by children
as the precursor to adult interaction
and he made some very interesting
observations about games you know
especially pretend games which are quite
sophisticated because children will get
together and play for 10 games and what
they'll do is
they act out a simulation of the world
maybe they play house they all get
together and they cast each other in
different
roles and then they each act out those
rules and they do that in order to
simulate something important that
they're going to have to adapt to
but piaget noted a couple of things the
first thing he noted was that
children playing games can play the
games in a group
thank you very much can play a game in a
group
but if you take them out of the group
and you ask them what the rules of the
game are
they don't know they can't articulate
the rules of the game
yet when you put them together in the
group they can play the game
and i thought oh that's just like adults
you see
because because well because we wouldn't
need a psychology otherwise right
because we'd all be transparent to
ourselves already
so what that means is when we all get
together and play a game like the one
that we're playing in this room for
example
we all can play the game when we're
together but if we brought us out
and said well what are the rules we
wouldn't be able to articulate them
and then i thought well that means that
those rules evolved in a real sense like
they
evolved in a behavioral competition and
i thought well that's
that's a lot like what's happening with
animals if you look at how a chimpanzee
troop is
organized or a wolf pack any social
animal for that matter going way down
the phylogenetic chain
they have to interact with one another
in a manner that that
sustains the group because otherwise
they all die obviously and it sustains
the individuals within the group and
offers the individual some
some scope of action and so there's a
set of implicit constraints
on the manner in which creatures
interact or they don't
live and and piaget also came to the
same conclusion with regards to
children's games
and and this is where he made a
distinction that's so crucial because
piaget was actually interested in
bridging the gap between science and
religion that was his fundamental
his fundamental motivation although very
few people know that and he was
interested in
bridging the gap between science and
ethics and and he was interested in how
ethics
evolved as a as a concept and then as a
practically applicable
um as something that was practically
applicable he made some very interesting
comments about games
and said well look what what constitutes
a good game
uh well one rule is uh everybody plays
voluntarily
that's a really good game and then he
made another claim which was quite cool
which was
imagine that you had a game a in game b
and they were competing
against the target and in in game b
people were being forced to play in a
game a people were playing voluntarily
and then you tracked their track record
with regards to competitive advantage
over time
the the game that people were playing
voluntarily would win because the people
who were playing wouldn't have to waste
any effort in enforcement cost
i thought oh god that's so smart it's so
smart because
because you can see the idea of the
emergence of an ethic theory
and and not an ethic that's rationally
constructed it's an ethic that's
actually emerging from the bottom up now
the philosopher friedrich nietzsche also
pointed out that our
that our ethic actually emerged from the
bottom up it wasn't rational it wasn't
top down it wasn't enlightenment
oriented even though the enlightenment
might have codified it
as part of a process of a codification
that took place over a very long period
of time
and so and then i read other things some
say about the way that animals organize
their troops
this was later but but but it's relevant
to our talk today that primatologists
friends to all for example has tried to
find out what makes chimpanzee troops
stable across time
you know you kind of have this idea that
a chimpanzee troop is
driven let's say by the most dominant
powerful male the most aggressive
cruel tyrannical chimpanzee dominates
and
that isn't what friends to all found
what he found was that
in order that those sorts of chimpanzee
troops have leaders that meet very
violent ends
because no matter how tyrannical you are
as top chimp two chimps three quarters
your size
can take you out and they will and
chimpanzees are unbelievably
unbelievably brutal and very very strong
and so tyrannical chimpanzee troops are
unstable
it's like that's a major league
discovery ma'am because it starts to
it starts to open up the possibility
that the ethic upon which functional
states are predicated is far deeper than
any
mere story or any mere rationality and
that's a really exciting possibility
because
what it means is that there might be
something at the bottom of our ethic
that's really there it's not just some
arbitrary constructed narrative it's not
just
one set of ways to live in the world
among many and i would say i would say
and i tried to outline this partly in 12
rules for life and
more in detail and maps of meaning that
the evidence on that is already in
is that there is a there is a convergent
ethic
that emerges from the bottom up over
evolutionary spans of time
over millions of years over hundreds of
thousands of years over tens of
thousands of years
as people learn how to act in a manner
that sustains them
as individuals now and a week from now
and a month from now and a year from now
so it has to be iteratable
that sustains them and their families
simultaneously it sustains them
and their families and their communities
across all those time frames
simultaneously and that's a very very
tight set of constraints and so
there might be a very large number of
ways to interpret the world as the
post-modern
most modernists accurately have it but
there are not
a very large number of ways to exist
successfully in the world in fact it's
extraordinarily constrained
it's constrained by the necessity of
playing an
iterative voluntary game and that's a
tight constraint as any of you who are
married know
right well i mean i mean i mean this
absolutely definitively because
you see the marriage is a very
interesting balancing act because
it has to be good for you and it has to
be good for your wife let's say
but it also has to be good for the two
of you and it has to and maybe that's
super ordinary to each of you as
individuals
and it has to be good for you in in a
way that's good for your children and
that has to work in society and it has
to be something that you can play out
moment by moment an hour to hour
and day to day and month to month and
week to week and you know
you know perfectly well that there isn't
much deviation from the straight narrow
path if you're going to play that game
because there's just too many ways of
falling into trouble and there's way
more ways of falling into trouble
than not falling into trouble okay so so
that's the first thing so imagine this
so this is the this is the idea
so the ethic emerges from the bottom up
as we learn how to organize ourselves in
ever more complex
societies sustainable societies and we
don't know what we're doing
okay but then what happens is because
we're insanely curious and capable of
self-recognition
we start to tell stories about how it is
that we're acting
and the stories have two forms one story
is about
the structures that we exist in and
that's the stories about other people
and every story is about other people
right because we live in a social world
you never see a story you never go to a
movie you never read a novel
that isn't about society and no wonder
because that's our environment society
so stories are about society
and they're about how societies succeed
and fail and they're about how
individuals within that society succeed
or fail because what we're trying to do
is to watch ourselves and i mean again
over the massive historical time frame
we're trying to watch how it is that we
act when we act properly and figure out
how to do it as individuals
and the first way we do that is to code
it in stories that's what stories are
for
that's what great literature is for
that's why there are great villains and
great heroes in great literature
because you want to know how to be a
great hero unless you want to be a great
villain
and if you want to be a great hero you
can learn from great villains the
opposite of how to act and so you get
you get incredible incredibly
sophisticated representations emerging
out of that process so
that take on an archetypal form so for
example the
the the motif of the hostile brothers
which is developed into cr
in christianity into the the twin
adversaries of christ and satan or cain
and abel
are the idea of the hero who thrives
in the social world and brings renewal
to the cosmos so to speak against the
deadly adversary
and that's exactly what you need to know
and again it's not arbitrary
it's not an arbitrary set of
propositions it's predicated on the
observation of successful and
unsuccessful patterns of behavior over
very very very very
long stretches of time so there's a
behavioral platform
and then there's a a narrative
representation of that platform then the
two things start to interact because
once you have drama
and literature you can learn from drama
and literature and alter how you behave
and your ethic becomes portable and then
what happens
after that is that
what happens after that is that thinkers
who now have both the behavioral strata
and the representational strata in front
of them
right the procedural ethic the
behavioral ethic plus the story
representation
step one step back from that especially
after it's written down
this is why why it works like the bible
or so of such critical importance
because
the the pattern the dramatic patterns
are then written down
and then you can step back from them
with your consciousness and you can
start to analyze them for their
for the rule-based content you see that
emerging to some degree in the story of
moses that's actually what's laid out in
part in the story of moses because
moses is leading his people through the
desert and watching how they fight and
watching how they behave
and then he has this so it's all very
very dramatic then he has this
tremendous revelation which is this is
how we
already act right and so what happens is
the rules are codified on the basis of
the observation of the patterns that are
already
extend that are functional as a
transformation of consciousness
at that point you have your ethic which
is far deeper than anything that you can
imagine
start to be articulated out into the
body of laws
and that's the point at which you have
let's say true philosophy in the
beginning of the body of laws it's
called the body of laws for a reason
and so well i thought that was all just
amazing to have
to have to have observed that to think
about that bottom-up process
and then i started reading a lot of
religious mythology
and i ran across this motif that was
developed very in in great detail by a
romanian um merce elliada who was a
great scholar of religions who
wrote remarkable remarkable books
including a history of religious ideas
which is
a highly recommended book and he talked
about this
interesting motif that i had run across
in other writings on mythology and
and in religious stories which was the
battle of the gods in heaven across
time and one of the things iliadi
pointed out was that if you if you
looked at the development of religious
systems so
say the development of the religious
system that came to dominate mesopotamia
when the mesopotamian tribes
came together so imagine each of those
tribes had their own god right and then
when they came together
that was terribly fractious because you
know what happens when different people
with different gods get together it's
it's ugly it's ugly and it's no wonder
because you know they
each have an ethic and they they're
living within the ethic and they're
using it to structure their worlds but
the ethics apparently
collide and so what happens at the
civilizational level is that
there's constant negotiation and
cognitive transformation
within the individual populations but
that's represented
over the large span of time as a battle
between the gods that represent the
different tribes in heaven
and so then what happens across time is
all those gods organize themselves into
a hierarchy
and one god comes out on top and that
god is the supreme god
and then the societies like mesopotamia
this happened in mesopotamia it also
happened in ancient greece they assumed
that their sovereign is
that the person who acts out the
sovereign god
because you might say well where does
the concept of sovereignty come from
right if it's not just brute force and
it's not because brute force doesn't
work
it has to have some other basis what's
the basis of sovereignty
what's the basis of authority not power
authority competence authority
right well how's that played out it's
played out by the battle between ethics
systems of ethics that are represented
in religious language across vast epochs
of time
and then the societies of gods let's say
organize themselves into a hierarchy and
they have a god at the top
and that's actually laid right out in in
the enumerage for example which is the
oldest
creation story that we have and out of
which
it's derived from the same what would
you say cultural substrate as the
stories in genesis for example
although it represents a variant the the
uh
mesopotamians had all their gods
aggregate themselves
together because they were threatened by
the unknown that's what happens in the
in the mesopotamian creation myth the
unknown gives rise to the gods
they become very fractious and compete
and then the unknown decides to destroy
them again like god destroying
noah noah's people in the flood it's the
same basic idea there's an idea there
and the idea is that
we emerge out of the unknown and we're
always threatened by it
not only as individuals but as a group
and that means that we need to figure
out what it is that should guide us in
order to continually confront the
unknown
and prevail and so what happens in
mesopotamia is the gods all get together
in a congress
and they basically they elect a new god
and he's a new kind of god
his name is marduk by the way he has
eyes all the way around his head
and so he pays attention that's not the
same as thinking
it's a different thing attention it's
the same thing the egyptians represented
in worship with the
eye of horus the idea that what you
should do if you want to survive in this
world
if you want to play a voluntary game
that everybody can participate in
your bloody eyes better be open because
they're the things that will save you
and that's attention
and the other thing that martic did he
spoke magic words
and so when he spoke the night sky would
appear the day sky would appear and so
the mesopotamians figured out in their
great religious story
that the fundamental sovereign god was
he who pays attention and speaks the
truth
and that's something that's something
that's
that's not something you punish people
for
right because there's this this is the
deepest idea of mankind
it's developed in detail in genesis in
the old testament it's the fundamental
idea of genesis that
god uses the logos the word of god to
cast
potential which we all face that's what
we face potential right you know that
you know that the future is unstructured
you have a
you have a potential within you that can
meet that and there's a potential that
characterizes the future
you meet it with eyes open and with
truthful speech and that's what happens
in genesis because god uses the logos
which is truthful speech
to cast the pre-cosmogonic potential
into habitable order
and then he says it's good and there's a
hint there
right because you think well is
habitable order good because life is
very difficult
it's a real question whether or not the
order that we inhabit is good
and the hypothesis in the old testament
is that if truthful speech gives
rise to the order then that order will
be good
and that's really something man like
that's really something to apprehend
it's a fundamental theological
presupposition
that the way that you take the potential
upon which the cosmos is predicated
and cast it into the order that allows
everyone to thrive
is by using truthful speech
wouldn't it be something if that was the
case and the thing is you know it's the
case
you know it you know it because you do
not admire yourself if you're deceitful
you admire yourself when you have those
rare moments in your life where you can
actually stand up
and say what's true regardless of the
cost and
if you if you give that respect to other
people if you treat them as if they're
the local of the divine speech that
casts potential into habitable order
then they like you maybe they even love
you and they get along with you and you
can work with them and you can cooperate
with them and you can compete with them
so not only is it the the fundamental
axiom that regulates your relationship
with yourself
it's the fundamental axiom that
regulates your interactions with other
people and if you do not give them that
that honor which is the the
presupposition for their natural right
right
because you're the idea that you have a
natural right is the idea that you have
some sort of intrinsic value
if you don't treat people as if they
have that intrinsic rate they are not
happy with you
even if they don't know why because
everyone wants to be treated as if
they have free will and as if they
confront potential and as if they're
capable of making moral choices
and that they should be rewarded when
they do things right and perhaps
punished when they do things wrong
everyone wants that and everyone knows
it and so
well so what does that all have to do
with free speech well
yes everything that's exactly right so
free speech isn't free speech you know
people think of free speech as
kind of like a decoration something like
that in your life
it's not that at all it's not the
ability to speak truth to power although
it is also that
it's not that it's way more than that
free speech is how you think it's not
thinking you know
the the word that that genesis
relies on to create the cosmos let's say
in the story by the way that's the image
of god in which you're made
male and female that gives you that
fundamental value that's at the core
of our idea of natural right it's not
thinking
it's speaking and the reason for that is
look first of all you can hardly think
it's really hard to think you have to be
trained like mad to think
you have to be able to divide yourself
internally into a couple of different
people
and then you have to let those people
have a war in your head and that means
you have to develop
characters who have opinions in great
detail opinions that might be contrary
to your own
and then you have to withstand the
tension of letting them have it out
and you only see that thinking in great
literature like you see that in
dostoyevsky he's an absolute master of
that
and you know you can think a little bit
but mostly you're biased and
you have confirmation bias and you see
things the way you see them and you have
massive blind spots and you're ignorant
as hell you just
you just you just can't think but you
can talk
and the thing is if you talk other
people will correct you
that's the thing and that's thinking so
if you get up and you have some
something to say and you say it stupidly
because of course you will because what
you know
then other people will tell you where
you're wrong and then you can learn
right and then everybody can think and
so what that also means is that
to be free to speak even to tell the
truth
means you have to be free to be stupid
and ignorant and malevolent and bitter
because that is who you are that is what
you are because you're flawed
[Applause]
so the idea that you know you can't use
your free speech if it's offensive it's
just
it's an idea that is so out you don't
know if it's naivety
out does its malevolence it's a real
battle which of the which of those two
things are worse i would go with
malevolence
because it detracts it attacks something
that's so absolutely fundamental
it's like well of course people who are
speaking freely are going to be
offensive
i mean have you ever had a serious
discussion with anyone in your life and
i mean a serious discussion i mean the
sort of discussion you have
when you're with your wife when you're
wondering whether your marriage is going
to survive
or or with your kids when they've done
something that is really not in their
best long-term interest i mean a serious
discussion
you can't even get off the ground
without being offensive you can't get
off the ground without offending
yourself in a conversation like that you
don't even want to admit
how you feel or how you think to
yourself if you think you can have a
difficult conversation without offending
people
all that means is you're not having a
difficult conversation
because well an easy conversation by
definition
no one gets upset about that there's no
real problem there's no real
disagreement
there's and there's no real real world
problem to be solved
it's just trivial it's like discussing
you know last night's sports event
there's nothing to it
if you're going to have a conversation
about something that matters you know
and the world is made out of what
matters that's a good thing to remember
if you're going to have a discussion
about what matters if you're really
going to talk about it
everyone is going to be offended by that
especially if there's something rotten
in the state of denmark and you happen
to be the one
opponent that is pointing it out so then
you think well
your freedom of speech that's not about
you being able to speak truth to power
that's about you being able to chart
your destiny in the world and more than
that it's it's even more than that's
important enough because
you know life is hard if you don't get
to think when you
when you walk through your life you will
fall into a pit there's no doubt about
that because that's what thinking is for
is to stop you from having any more
catastrophes that are absolutely
necessary
and it's a terribly difficult process
and so if if that's interfered with
it isn't that you don't get to speak
truth to power it's that you do not get
to
act in the world in a manner that allows
you to
to eliminate endless unnecessary hellish
suffering
and not just for you but for you and
your family and your community and so
the enemies of free speech they are the
enemies of the process that turns
potential into habitable order
they're enemies of the divine principle
and worse they're their own enemies
right because this isn't well some of us
believe in free speech and some of us
don't
it's way deeper than that if you don't
believe in free speech you don't believe
in the implicit divinity of mankind you
don't believe in the sovereignty of the
individual
you don't believe in sovereignty as such
you're a totalitarian of some sort which
means you attribute all the divine power
to yourself
it's and then we know where that leads
right it doesn't matter whether it's on
the right or the left
if we had any sense and we took a look
at 20th century history we know exactly
where things go
and we could easily choose not to go
there and so when we see someone like
raith who's imprisoned by a
reprehensible dictatorship
that we have the gall to call our allies
then what we see is
a a system that's not only hell bent on
the destruction
of an innocent and good man but but
directly antithetical to everything that
all of us have and that our societies
put forward
as necessary to the continual betterment
of being itself and so
no and i've been so absolutely appalled
by the western world
we need response to the attacks of
totalitarians upon our freedom of speech
the what was done with salman rushdie
that was a big
big big big mistake right because it
wasn't rusty it was
the free speaking artistic tradition of
the west
and not only of the west right the free
speaking artistic creative tradition
upon which
the cosmos is properly established
that's what it was and we all bowed down
we all bowed down with no resistance
whatsoever it was a massive error we're
going to pay for that for a very long
time
we did the same thing with the danish
cartoons
[Applause]
and you don't want to think about these
sorts of things as happening far away
nothing happens far away when it happens
somewhere else it's happening right here
too and that's why we're all here today
because we recognize that
at least on some level and we have to
stop
we need to stop being so naive about our
let's say our moral relativism we need
to take a look at history and biology in
a very very
fundamental way and we need to really
understand what our culture
what our culture and and genuine
cultures everywhere are predicated on
and that is the idea that
the sovereign voice of the individual is
the power that
casts potential into habitable being and
restructures tyrannical order when it
needs to be restructured
right and that's what each of us are
that's the divine presence in each of us
and i do believe that there is no more
fundamental truth than that
i don't believe that you can dig down
underneath that i think that's bedrock
that's the foundation
stone of the house that's the
cornerstone of the house
and it requires everyone to courageously
confront the tyranny that's them
and the unknown that surrounds them and
to work for their own benefit and for
the benefit of their families and for
the benefit of their communities
and to do everything they can to benefit
the world and to live
with true speech as the highest value
that's how we sort out the world
and we can sort it out we are sorting it
out a very rapid rate and we could do
that much
much more effectively if i do believe
that it's incumbent on us to understand
the absolutely fundamental role that
these processes take i know we're here
today
because we all have at least an
intimation of that right we know that
there's something about free speech
that's so central that we cannot
allow attacks on it to go unchallenged
no matter where they occur
but it's very useful to have it
articulated and to know that this is
bedrock right and it's not something
arbitrary it's not a mere game a mere
game that
we're only playing in the west none of
that it's something it's the most
fundamental truth that the human race
has ever discovered
and we we lose it at our absolute peril
and it's not death it's worse than not
the peril because there are worse things
than
death and the worst thing than death is
hell and we saw plenty of that in the
20th century
and when we let freedom of speech go
that's where we're headed
and unless we want to go there then we
should stop aiming for it
[Applause]
so well thank you very much for the
invitation
good night
you